okay
well Dave once again great I appreciate
your time and and can you kind of take
me through the the timeline of of where
you got to where you once were to where
you are today
well yeah it's been a big week you know
we entered into a purchase and sale
agreement on 49 Acres right across from
T-Mobile next to the In-N-Out burger
right there where the Wild West Casino
used to be to build a new stadium for
the A's for relocation to Las Vegas so
it's a great site good for locals easy
to get in and out of in the resort
Corridor for tourists we're really
excited about it and we're excited to
make this big milestone uh announcement
to the public well it's an exciting time
obviously and when you think of uh I go
back in fact I think it was 2001 when
you tweeted out uh wow Stanley Cup
playoffs in Vegas they're waving the
towels and that view got 210
000 likes or whatever views oh yeah it
was it was very popular yes yeah that's
what I was saying so did the the knights
and that early success kind of say wow
something could actually work in Vegas
we have been so impressed from day one
which has been almost two years ago of
looking at Las Vegas as a potential
market for the A's with the local
support and especially with the golden
knights with the Raiders with the
aviators the local community Gets behind
their teams and for us in baseball with
so many events and dates that's
critically important you know 70 of our
fans are going to be locals and we want
to you know make sure that we have an
incredible team to watch and we're very
competitive in winning world series but
we want to make sure that they actually
love baseball and I think that fan base
is out there and tapping into that is an
exciting aspect of the team coming to
town is it almost fair to say that the
night's success and what they did
kind of led to the decisions that you
guys are making like wow if they can
have that kind of success we got to take
a real real close and hard look
absolutely I think before their success
when people did studies or thought about
Las Vegas as a market they couldn't even
you know fathom the level of rabid fan
base of the local market and when you
add the tourists on top of that you know
you get this great combination that
allows you to have a business that's
very very successful and a fan
environment that's fun to go to like
when you go to a Golden Knights game or
go to a Raiders game like it's exciting
to see that energy and and we want to
bring that to our new baseball stadium
uh there at the wild west site Dave is
funny a while back I can't remember
maybe it's been two years or even longer
I actually got a survey from you guys
here at my house and I'm kind of
wondering I don't know how that was all
widespread throughout the valley but I
actually got one and I was kind of
wondering what did you guys learn or
glean from that survey about the Las
Vegas Market well we we did a survey of
thousands of local residents we also did
10 or 12 focus groups and then we did
intercept surveys in a lot of other
markets to see if people would travel in
for games I think we heard loud and
clear from people have a
climate-controlled environment for the
games in the summer which we're going to
have because we're going to have a dome
or a partially retractable Dome and also
have somewhere that's easy to get in and
out of and that's one reason we chose
this site because it's on it's west of
the 15 you're gonna have on-site parking
it's going to be easy to get to from
either Summerlin or Henderson or other
areas in the greater Las Vegas area and
that's going to make a big difference
for people to come to 10 12 14 games
um and so that's really an important
North Star for us uh to determine the
location and one reason we picked that
site are you guys thinking I read
somewhere or maybe I just might have
been a rumor are you guys actually
thinking about maybe putting together a
bridge like Allegiant stadium has that
Hacienda that they shut down for games
yes are you guys doing something like
that maybe we're looking at that our
designers are looking at potentially
extending Park Avenue you know that's
right by T-Mobile over in a pedestrian
overcrossing right into our Stadium
right into the Outfield and so you'd be
able to just walk right over that'd be
great for tourists it would create a
great connection to
um the casinos and resorts Park MGM New
York New York and all the other resorts
in that area so I think it could be a
great addition and really extend the
vibrancy of the strip but also provide
an easy area in and out for locals
because you don't need to fight the
traffic to get into the strip areas so
it could be the best of both worlds
here's kind of a tough question oh you
can't answer right now but maybe just if
if the thought is even there with John
be even up to this have you thought
about maybe even just rebranding it kind
of become a New Vegas franchise and out
with the old in with the new kind of
thing is that even a thought
well you know the A's go all the way
back to the founding of the American
League in 1901. so we have an incredible
Heritage you know we've had success in
multiple markets Philadelphia Kansas
City Oakland
um and so the brand and the name is very
powerful and one that we want to retain
and move forward with
um and really create a new chapter of
its history and success in the Las Vegas
Valley
was there a time Dave that you that that
maybe made you realize you know what
it's not going to work in Oakland we've
we've got to move on was there a turning
point tip the scales at some point and
when was well I think I think the league
imposing the deadline of January of next
year to have a binding agreement on a
new stadium that was a big deal because
that put out there a hard deadline that
we had to achieve and I think that
really accelerated our efforts in Las
Vegas we've been greeted from the first
day with open arms in Las Vegas people
have been so positive can do to make
this happen helping us through the site
selection market feasibility now helping
with the public-private partnership
um the governor has been fantastic and
welcoming and so all these things have
contributed to us feeling that there's a
great path in southern Nevada for
um a relocation and for the team to have
success and that's why we're excited
about moving forward and achieving this
big milestone today
tell me when you plan to uh break ground
and uh when you plan to throw the first
pitch at this new unnamed ballpark
hopefully next year we'd break ground
and we'd open in 2027 so before you know
it we'll be playing Major League
Baseball in town well that's one thing
and I think I mentioned until you or you
might even mention it to me a way back
when we first talked how Vegas is when
you think of construction it is a can-do
kind of City they get things done here
and get them done quickly and you know
working with the different unions
especially the Building Trades is an
important aspect of this and ensuring
that we have union labor that's a big uh
positive is something we've always done
and we're excited about that in Las
Vegas how easy was that negotiating with
the fertittas who owned that land right
there I mean they're they're they're
great guys everybody knows the Lorenzo I
mean the fertittas are a big name big
big company here with the stations and
how was that negotiation
well you know we've had plenty
negotiations on all these different
potential land deals with a lot of
variety of people and it's been great
working with the Fertitta family and
getting to a positive outcome and we
greatly appreciate their um you know
willingness to engage with us and do a
land sale because without it we couldn't
move forward and so that is it's great
to see that and we look forward to
taking the next step now getting the
public-private partnership finalized and
then filing for relocation that's all I
wanted to ask you what how do you what
are you looking at in terms of a public
private deal I know that that that's got
to be part of the plan what what what's
what's the latest
well we're working you know with um
Governor Lombardo
um Nicole canizarro in the Senate Steve
Yeager with the assembly all the
leadership Clark County Jim Gibson to
ensure that we put together a package
that's fiscally responsible that ensures
that it's done in a way that uh is
accretive and beneficial to
um the public sector you know we're
going to be contributing the land that
we purchased to the public as part of a
stadium District like Allegiant and
seeing how Allegiance has been so
successful at drawing so many people
bringing incremental tourists that have
generated a lot of Revenue uh for Social
Services Public Safety we think this
Stadium can do a similar thing and we're
we've been working with Jeremy Aguero
and applied analysis on all the analysis
and just being thoughtful about
approaching this and doing it on a
timeline that works for them uh is
something that we want to do and
hopefully come to some positive
resolution this summer
I got a figure that besides baseball you
will definitely kind of like what you
mentioned there you'll definitely have
is that maybe why you're you're
expanding to 30 possibly thirty five
thousand and if that is the number where
you envision soccer and other events and
concerts inside this uh retractable
don't touch Stadium we're gonna
definitely have other events and I think
you know it's going to be everything
from concerts to like you said soccer
matches and you know really having a
venue of that size 30 35
000 I think is going to be a sweet spot
and we're really excited about that it's
an amenity that can attract events like
the World Baseball Classic it was just
incredible this year or the All-Star
Game and just things that are currently
not possible in Las Vegas and I think
that's something that everyone is is
very excited about
let me ask you if you had a 100 fans
that were sitting right here and they
wanted to hear from you
um and they don't want to pay a lot out
of their pocket they don't want taxes to
go up and so forth but they want
baseball they love baseball they want to
come to the games what would be the
message you would have to the Las Vegas
community
but what I would say is that you know
investing in a stadium in a responsible
fashion creates a positive Roi so not
only do you get a team and you know all
the benefits you know of quality of life
and the community aspects but it
actually generates a lot of new tourists
who pay a lot of taxes that help the
entire economy of Southern Nevada and
even Nevada in general kind of go and
these are the types of economic
developments that have occurred over the
last generation that have created kind
of the modern Miracle of Las Vegas from
an economic perspective it's really a
model in terms of how Economic
Development can be done and it can
enhance the quality of life of the
community so that's what we're hoping to
do we want to do an in responsible
fashion and we hope to have meaningful
dialogue continue with all the relevant
parties all right Dave final question I
got to ask you why will fans be so
excited once you uh throw that first
pitch out in 2027 give me the whole
Envision what do you what do you
envision and why are fans gonna say man
I can't wait
well it's gonna be a spectacle you know
baseball has always been about
promotions especially the A's going back
to Charlie Finley and you know
everything from the orange baseball to
The Mule he used to ride around on so I
think we're going to continue the
tradition of promotions I think that's
going to fit in perfectly in Las Vegas
it's going to be a lot of fun and
excitement and then we've always had a
great brand of baseball young exciting
players that you can get behind that are
Scrappy and gritty and and win you know
we've had a long history of winning we
have won nine World Championships we've
been in a tunnel World Series American
League pennants and we want to bring
that same history of success
um to Las Vegas and I'm sure John's
going to have to open his walls a little
bit and get some of those players in
here so you guys do win right we're
gonna have a much larger payroll I mean
we're going to have a lot more resources
and to give that type of resources to
Billy Bean and David Forrest on our
baseball side look out it's going to be
really really compelling is Don Logan do
you guys maybe plan on if you have to
play a few a year maybe here in Vegas
well we've actually we have an agreement
with the aviators with Don and Howard
Hughes to to play at their Stadium
temporarily
um we're really deferring to Major
League Baseball to kind of help us make
that decision it really depends on the
CBA and the union and but that is a
possibility and it may happen and it's
important to remember that you know once
we come the aviators are going to stay
it's going to be like the golden knights
and the silver Knights and having two
you know teams in town at the same time
it's going to be great for Player
Development and it's going to be awesome
for our fans to be able to see these
young players develop and make it to the
show oh that's very cool uh Elon Musk is
building these tunnels underneath the
city or Las Vegas have you made sure
that he makes a stop there at least a
tunnel to the the new ballpark we spoke
to Steve Davis at the boring company and
yes a stop is in our future maybe two so
yes that's gonna happen and that might
be a super easy way to get in and out of
there well I think fans are going to
have a good time Dave oh for sure it's
gonna it's gonna be fantastic and we
really appreciate you covering the story
and being so knowledgeable about
everything that's happening well Dave
thank you I appreciate that hopefully we
can chat sooner than later awesome take
care my friend thank you very much I
appreciate that
thank you